Let's talk a little bit more about the technique of completing the square. Now
we've used this a lot to figure out how to get equations for parabolas in vertex
form but we can also use it to factor expressions and to solve other equations.
It's the technique that could be used in a ton of different circumstances. First
things first, let's see how we can use this to factor. Now earlier on in this
lesson, we saw that we could write this in a modified version of the equation in
vertex form as y equals the quantity x minus 4 squared minus 1. Notice that the
first term here is a squared term and the second term, apart from the minus
sign, is also a squareed term. Because we have one squared term that's being
subtracted from another squared term, we can call this an instance of difference
of squares. In genereal, if we have two squared terms, a squared and b squared
and we write a squared minus b squared then remember that we can factor this in
an interesting way. This is just equal to a plus b times a minus b. Match up our
difference of squares here, with this general form for the difference of
squares. Can you tell me what a and b are, in the case that we have right here
on the right side of our equation?